D
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT WILL JOIN
US, THE ONLY OPTION HE HAS LEFT
BUT FIRST WE BEGIN TONIGHT AND
JOE BIDEN'S DISASTROUS FIRST
TRIP ABROAD NOW ENTERING WEEK
TWO AND EUROPE'S LEADERS ARE
RELATED.
THERE'S NO TOUGH LOVE, THERE'S
NO AMERICA FIRST, NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
NO DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS, NO
NEGOTIATIONS, AMERICA LAST
POLICIES AS JOE KEEPS SAYING
AMERICA IS BACK, AMERICA LAST IS
BACK, AMERICA PAYING THE BILLS
FOR THE WORLD IS BACK AND JUST
WANTS EVERYONE TO GO ALONG AND
GET ALONG AND AS A RESULT, THE
WORLD IS ONCE AGAIN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF BIDEN'S TREMENDOUS
CLEAR WEAKNESS AND UTTER
STUPIDITY.
REMEMBER, WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT TO NATO AND
TOOK CHARGE AND HE STOOD UP FOR
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
MADE THEM UNCOMFORTABLE AND THEY
HAD TO PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
>> I HAVE BEEN VERY DIRECT WITH
SECRETARY STOLTENBERG AND
MEMBERS OF THE ALLIANCE IN
SAYING THAT NATO MEMBERS MUST
FINALLY CONTRIBUTE THEIR FAIR
SHARE AND MEET THEIR FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS.
>> Sean: NOW NATO ALLIANCE
MEMBERS HELPING MAKE
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND RUSSIA RICH
AGAIN DOING BILLION-DOLLAR
ENERGY DEALS THINGS TO JOE'S
WAIVER FOR VLADIMIR.
AS A RESULT, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
TOUGH RHETORIC AND ACTIONS, OUR
NATO ALLIES HAVE TO STEP UP.
CONTRIBUTING A LOT MORE,
BROKERED WITH THE U.K. AND FAIR
TRADE, THE PARIS CLIMATE ACCORDS
THAT DOES NOTHING TO HOLD CHINA
AND INDIA ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE
THEY ARE PACIFIED AND THE PARIS
ACCORD IN DEVELOPING COUNTRIES.
ALL WHILE SENDING YOU TAX
DOLLARS AND MAKING YOU PAY FOR
PRETTY MUCH ALL OF IT, SOME KIND
OF GLOBAL PENANCE WHEN WE REDUCE
MORE GREENHOUSE GASES THAN ANY
COUNTRY ON EARTH, UNSURPRISINGLY
THE CLIMATE OBSESSED SOCIALIST
OF EUROPE DON'T WANT TO PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE, THEY MUCH
PREFER JOE BIDEN WHO CARES MORE
ABOUT THEIR APPROVAL THAN THE
WELL-BEING OF VIEW, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BUT TO BE HONEST, IT'S
NOT CLEAR THAT JOE BIDEN STILL
POSSESSES THE STRENGTH, THE
ENERGY, AND THE ABILITY TO EVEN
KNOW WHAT THE WORD TOUGH MEANS.
JOE BIDEN ONCE REFERRING TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN AS A KILLER BUT
NOW AHEAD OF HIS MEETING WITH
THE HOSTILE PRESIDENT, TOUGH
TALK NUMBER TO BE FOUND.
EVEN PUBLICLY AGREED TO CONSIDER
A PRISONER EXCHANGE, SOMETHING
IMMEDIATELY HIS HANDLERS HAD TO
BACKTRACK ON AND TODAY, HE
COULDN'T SEEM TO FIND THE WORDS
TO SAY ANYTHING AT ALL ABOUT
HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN LAUGHED AT THE
SUGGESTION THAT YOU HAVE CALLED
HIM A KILLER.
IS THAT STILL YOUR BELIEF THAT
HE IS A KILLER?
>> CAN ANSWER THE FIRST
QUESTION?
I'M LAUGHING TOO.
LOOK, HE HAS MADE CLEAR THAT --
THE ANSWER IS I BELIEVE HE HAS
IN THE PAST ESSENTIALLY
ACKNOWLEDGED CERTAIN THINGS THAT
HE WOULD DO OR DID DO.
>> Sean: FOR THOSE OF YOU IN
THE MEDIA MOB THAT GET ANGRY
WHEN I CALL HIM THE SIPPY CUP,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY I CALL HIM
SIPPY CUP, HE NEEDS IS MORE
MILKY, NINE NIGHT MORE MILK
SIPPY CUP TIME.
IT IS HUMILIATING.
RUSH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR TWO
MAJOR CYBER ATTACKS AGAINST OUR
COUNTRY IN RECENT WEEKS, JOE.
IT IS SUPPLYING AMERICA'S
ENEMIES WITH WEAPONS TECHNOLOGY
AND FUNDING SO THEY CAN FUND A
PROXY WAR WORLDWIDE ON TERROR
AGAINST THE NUMBER ONE STATE
SPONSOR OF TERROR.
THEIR AGGRESSIVE ACTIONS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND AROUND THE WORLD
ARE ENDANGERING AMERICA'S
SOLDIERS BUT JOE BIDEN IS AT A
LOSS FOR WORDS.
I'M SITTING THERE SAYING YOU CAN
DO IT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, RUSSIA IS A
HOSTILE REGIME.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS A HOSTILE
ACTOR.
YES, HE'S A KILLER AND HE IS A
THUG AND SIPPY CUP DOESN'T HAVE
THE STRENGTH AND MENTAL
FORTITUDE TO HAVE HER HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ANYTHING.
AT THIS MEETING IS GOING TO BE A
DISASTER.
PUTIN WILL SEE FIRSTHAND HOW
WEAK HE IS.
AND WITNESSING ALL THAT HE
PROTECTS JOE FROM, A MERE SHELL
OF THE MAN HE WAS EVEN FIVE
YEARS AGO, MAKE NO MISTAKE.
PUTIN LOVES A WEEK AMERICA AND A
WEAK AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE, THERE WON'T BE A
JOINT PRESS OR FOLLOWING THE
SUMMIT, CAN'T PUT JOEY IN THAT
POSITION.
WHATEVER BIDEN SAYS ABOUT PUTIN
AFTER THE MEETING, THEY WROTE
THAT BEFORE THEY EVER WENT ON
THIS TRIP, I GUARANTEE YOU IT'S
ALREADY BEEN WRITTEN.
JOE IS AFRAID, HIS STAFF IS
AFRAID, THEY ARE WORRIED THAT
WHAT JOE SAYS IN PRIVATE HE
WOULD NEVER SAY IN PUBLIC AND IT
WOULD JUST BE A TALKING POINT
AFTER THEY MEET ALONE BECAUSE
HE'S AFRAID TO SAY IN FRONT OF
PUTIN AND IN FRONT OF THE WORLD.
THEY ARE WORRIED PUTIN WILL
UPSTAGE HIM BECAUSE HE WILL AND
MAKE HIM LOOK BAD BECAUSE HE
WILL.
AND THEY ARE WORRIED BIDEN WILL
BE HUMILIATED WE GET A GET ON
THE GLOBAL STAGE AS IF THIS
WEEKEND WAS AN EMBARRASSING
ENOUGH.
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THE PAST FEW
DAYS, JOE HAS BEEN AN
EMBARRASSING INTERNATIONAL
LAUGHINGSTOCK.
THIS IS A GREAT MOMENT, AT
ONE POINT AND EUROPE'S LEADERS
ALL MARKING JOE RIGHT TO HIS
FACE AFTER HE BECAME INCREDIBLY
CONFUSED DURING THE MEETING.
THEN HE HAD TO TELL THE
PRIME MINISTER OF GREAT BRITAIN
MAYBE YOU SHOULD INTRODUCE THE
PRESIDENT OF SOUTH AFRICA.
I ALREADY DID, JOE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Sean: THIS ISN'T EVEN FUNNY
ANYMORE.
THAT WASN'T THE ONLY MOMENT OF
CONFUSION.
THERE WERE A LOT.
BIDEN MIXED UP LIBYA AND SYRIA,
DID IT THREE CONSECUTIVE TIMES
IN LESS THAN 90 SECONDS.
THAT HAS TO BE A RECORD.
NOT ONE TO BE FOND OF, BUT A
RECORD NONETHELESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CAN WORK TOGETHER WITH
RUSSIA.
FOR EXAMPLE -- AND LIBYA, WE
SHOULD BE OPENING UP THE PASSES
TO BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH AND
PROVIDE FOOD ASSISTANCE AND
ECONOMIC -- VITAL ASSISTANCE TO
A POPULATION THAT'S IN REAL
TROUBLE, THE REBUILDING OF
SYRIA, OF LIBYA.
THEY ARE THERE.
I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN FIND
ACCOMMODATION OR WE CAN SAVE THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE IN
LIBYA.
>> Sean: AS THEY WERE A LINE
ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS TAKING OVER?
I KNOW WHERE I WOULD BET.
ONCE AGAIN, HIS HANDLERS FORCED
TO ISSUE ANOTHER CLARIFICATION
AND IT GETS WORSE DURING THE
SAME REMARKS AT TIMES HIS
COMMENTS MADE ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE WHAT WHATSOEVER AND I'M
NOT MAKING THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DOSES OF PFIZER VACCINE WHICH
WE CONTRACTED AND PAID FOR IN
ADDITION TO MONEY WE PUT INTO
THE COVID PROJECT WHICH I KNOW
YOU ALL KNOW BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
MAY NOT KNOW WHAT COVID IS BY
HARASSING THE FULL POTENTIAL OF
THOSE WHO ARE HARASSING, WE WILL
HAVE TO TRY TO CHANGE THINGS.
THAT'S THE WHOLE IDEA.
>> Sean: WHO ON EARTH DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT COVID IS?
THIS IS WHY THE ADMINISTRATION
WORKS OVERTIME TO LIMIT BIDEN'S
OFF SCRIPT PUBLIC INTERACTIONS,
EVEN THE FIRST LADY DOING HER
PART OVER THE WEEKEND LITERALLY
TO JUMP IN AND DRAG JOE AWAY
WHEN HE SEEMED TO BE IN THE
WRONG CAFETERIA TO PREVENT HIM
FROM ANSWERING AN IMPROMPTU
QUESTION AND AGAIN, ADMITTED ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO ANSWER TO MANY
QUESTIONS, THEY WON'T LET ME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THANK YOU.
I MAY GET IN TROUBLE WITH MY
STAFF, GO AHEAD.
>> YOU HAVE SAID REPEATEDLY THAT
AMERICA IS BACK.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU'VE KEPT IN
PLACE SOME TRUMP ERA STEEL AND
ALUMINUM SANCTIONS AND I WANTED
TO ASK YOU WHEN YOU ARE HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH
EUROPEAN ALLIES, WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE SANCTIONS,
HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY THAT AND WHAT
ARE YOUR PLANS?
>> 120 DAYS, GIVE ME A BREAK.
NEED TIME.
>> Sean: COME ON, MAN, ARE YOU
A JUNKIE?
I EXPECTED THAT THE COME FLYING
OUT.
HE OF THE PRESIDENT, YOU'VE BEEN
IN OFFICE FOR 145 DAYS AND YOU
CAN ANSWER AS MANY QUESTIONS AS
YOU WANT, THIS IS FRANKLY BEYOND
CONCERNING BECAUSE AMERICA IS
ENTERING AN EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING.
MACK MAJOR GROWING THREATS
ABROAD, CHINA, RUSSIA, IRAN,
NORTH KOREA JUST TO NAME A FEW
AND AT THE SAME TIME, NEW
SERIOUS PROBLEMS HERE AT HOME.
A MASSIVE INFLATION, VIOLENT
CRIME ON THE RISE, LAWLESSNESS
AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AIDED AND
ABETTED BY JOE, THESE ARE TO
SERIOUS CHALLENGES, JOE IS
CLEARLY NOT UP TO THIS JOB AND
PUTS ALL THIS EFFORT INTO JUST
GETTING THROUGH THE DAY BARELY.
HIS RADICAL SOCIALIST BASE WHICH
IS CLEARLY RUNNING THE SHOW CASE
IN POINT, THE BIGGEST
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE EUROPE TRIP
AN AGREEMENT TO CONSIDER A
GLOBAL CORPORATE TAX RATE WHICH
OF COURSE THEY DON'T PAY TAXES,
THEY PASSED THEM ON TO YOU AND
JOE KNOWS CORPORATIONS WILL
LEAVE THE U.S. SO HE'S TRYING TO
CONSPIRE WITH OTHER SOCIALIST
COUNTRIES TO ENSURE THERE IS NO
COUNTRY TO EVER EXIST.
THIS WILL END IN WORLDWIDE
ECONOMIC DISASTER AS A MATTER OF
FACT, THE ENTIRE TRIP